This episode of Real Engineering is brought
to you by Skillshare, home to over twenty
thousand classes that could teach you a new
life skill.
As the world grapples to eliminate fossil
fuels from our energy diet, electric cars
have seen an incredible boom over the past
few years.
Last year, over one million electric cars
were sold around the world.
The number of Nissan Leafs, Teslas, and other
electric vehicles in circulation worldwide
is now more than three million.
And while there are many brands of electric
car to choose from, there are only two choices
when it comes to powering electric vehicles:
fuel cells or batteries.
Both produce electricity to drive electric
motors, eliminating the pollution and inefficiencies
of the fossil fuel powered internal combustion
engine.
Both hydrogen and electricity for batteries
can be produced from low­ or zero ­carbon
sources, including renewable energy like solar
and wind, and therefore both are being pursued
by car manufacturers and researchers as the
possible future of electric vehicles.
However, a great debate is being waged by
supporters of each technology.
Elon Musk has called hydrogen fuel cell technology
“incredibly dumb,” claiming they’re
more of a marketing ploy for automakers than
a long-term solution.
In contrast, Japan has announced its intention
to become the world's first hydrogen society,
with the Japanese government and the auto
industry working together to introduce 160
hydrogen stations and 40,000 fuel-cell vehicles
by March 2021.
So which is actually better?
At first glance, hydrogen seems like an extremely
clever way to power a car.
Compressed hydrogen has a specific energy
(aka energy per unit mass) of neary 40,000
watt hours per kilogram.
Lithium ion batteries at best have a specific
energy of just 278 wh/kg, but most fall around
167 wh / kg.
That's 236 times as much energy per kg for
hydrogen.
And because of its energy density and lightweight
nature, compressed hydrogen and fuel cells
can power cars for extended ranges without
adding much weight, which as we saw in our
last video is a gigantic road block for incorporating
the technology into the aviation industry.
The designers of electric vehicles are caught
in a catch 22 with energy density and range.
Each extra kilogram of battery weight to increase
range requires extra structural weight, heavier
brakes, a higher torque motor, and in turn
more batteries to carry around this extra
mass, This weight compounding limits how far
a battery powered vehicle can travel, until
new technology can help reduce the weight
of the batteries.
For hydrogen fuel cell vehicles, this weight
compounding is not an issue.
Additionally, a hydrogen fuel cell vehicle
can be refueled in under 5 minutes, where
a battery powered electric vehicle, like the
Tesla model S, takes over 3 hours to fully
recharge.
When looking at the range and refuel times
hydrogen can offer, you can see why some car
manufacturers are investing in this technology.
On the face of it.
Hydrogen is a clear winner, but it falls behind
when we start considering the end-to-end production
process.
While both batteries and hydrogen fuel cells
are both forms of electricity storage, the
cost differ drastically.
Fully charging a Tesla Model 3 with a 75 kiloWatt
hour battery, costs between 10-12 dollars
depending where you live.
With a rated range of 500 kilometers, that’s
between 2 and 2.4 cent per kilometer.
A great price.
In a previous video, I visited a petrol station
that introduced a hydrogen pump, fed by its
own on-site production facility.
which used off-peak electricity to produce
hydrogen.
The hydrogen from this station cost $85 dollars
to fill the 5 kg tank of the Toyota Mirais
on site, which had a range of 480 kms.
That’s 17.7 cent per kilometer, 8 times
the price.
And here lies the problem, Hydrogen simply
requires more energy to produce.
To understand the economic viability of hydrogen
let’s dig deeper into the production process.
Before any hydrogen vehicle can hit the road,
you first need to produce the hydrogen, but
hydrogen is not a readily available energy
source.
Even though hydrogen is the most abundant
element in the universe, it is usually stored
in water, hydrocarbons, such as methane, and
other organic matter.
One of the challenges of using hydrogen as
an energy storage mechanism comes from being
able to efficiently extract it from these
compounds.
In the US, the majority of hydrogen is produced
through a process called steam reforming.
Steam reforming is the process of combining
high-temperature steam with natural gas to
extract hydrogen.
While steam reforming is the most common method
of industrial hydrogen production, it requires
a good deal of heat and is wildly inefficient.
Hydrogen produced by steam reforming actually
has less energy than the natural gas that
the steam reforming began with.
And while hydrogen fuel cells themselves don’t
produce pollution, this process does.
So if we want to assume a future scenario
with as little carbon emission as possible,
this method won’t cut it.
Another method to produce hydrogen is electrolysis
- separating the hydrogen out of water using
an electric current.
While the electricity needed for this process
can be provided from renewable sources, it
requires even more energy input than steam
reforming.
You end up losing 30% of the energy from the
original energy put in from the renewables
when you carry out electrolysis.
So we are sitting at 70% energy efficiency
from hydrogen fuel cells if traditional electrolysis
is used, before the car even starts its engine.
A slightly more efficient method of producing
hydrogen is polymer exchange membrane electrolysis.
Using this method, energy efficiencies can
reach up to 80%, with the added benefit of
being produced on site, which we will get
to in a moment.
But this is still a 20% loss of energy from
the original electricity from the renewables.
Some experts say the efficiency of PEM electrolysis
is expected to reach 82-86% before 2030, which
is a great improvement, but still well short
of batteries charging efficiency at 99%.
[1] A 19% difference in production costs doesn’t
explain the difference in costs yet, so where
else are we losing energy.
The next hurdle in getting hydrogen fuel cell
vehicles on the road is the transport and
storage of the pure hydrogen.
If we assume the hydrogen is produced on site,
like it was for this petrol station, then
we eliminate one energy sink, but the cost
of storage is just as problematic.
Hydrogen is extremely low density as a gas
and liquid, and so in order to achieve adequate
energy density, we have to increase its actual
density.
We can do this in two ways.
We can compress the hydrogen to 790 times
atmospheric pressure, but that takes energy,
about 13% of the total energy content of the
hydrogen itself.
Alternatively we can turn hydrogen into liquid,
cryogenically.
The advantage of hydrogen liquefaction is
that a cryogenic hydrogen tank is much lighter
than a tank that can hold pressurized hydrogen.
But again, hydrogen's physical properties
means hydrogen is harder to liquefy than any
other gas except helium.
Hydrogen is liquified by reducing its temperature
to -253°C, with an efficiency loss of 40%,
once you factor in the added weight of the
refrigerators and the refrigeration itself.
So pressurisation is a better option at a
13% energy loss.
Once the hydrogen is produced and compressed
to a liquid or gas, a viable hydrogen infrastructure
requires that hydrogen be able to be delivered
from where it's produced to the point of end-use,
such as a vehicle refueling station.
Where the hydrogen is produced can have a
big impact on the cost and best method of
delivery.
For example, a large, centrally located hydrogen
production facility can produce hydrogen at
a lower cost because it is producing more,
but it costs more to deliver the hydrogen
because the point of use is farther away.
In comparison, distributed production facilities
produce hydrogen on site so delivery costs
are relatively low, but the cost to produce
the hydrogen is likely to be higher because
production volumes are less.
While there are some small-scale, on-site
hydrogen production facilities being installed
at refuelling pumps, such as the station mentioned
in the last hydrogen video.
until this infrastructure is widespread, we
have to assume that the majority of hydrogen
is being transported by truck or pipeline,
where we know that energy losses can range
from 10% up to 40%.
In comparison, assuming that the electricity
that we use for charging the batteries comes
completely from renewable resources (like
solar or wind), we just have to consider the
transmission losses in the grid.
Using the United States grid as a reference
for typical grid losses, the average loss
is only 5%.
So in the best case scenario for hydrogen,
using the most efficient means of production
and transport, we lose 20% of energy during
PEM electrolysis, and around 13% for compression
and storage, amounting to a 33% loss.
In other systems, this could be as much as
56%.
For battery power, up to this point, we have
lost just 6% to the grid and recharging.
Bringing our best case efficiency difference
to 27% and our worst case to 50%.
The next stage of powering electric vehicles
is what is called the tank to wheel conversion
efficiency.
For hydrogen fuel cell vehicles, once the
hydrogen is in the tank, it must be re-converted
into electric power.
This is done via a fuel cell, which essentially
works like a PEM electrolyser, but in reverse.
In a PEM fuel cell, hydrogen gas flows through
channels to the anode, where a catalyst causes
the hydrogen molecules to separate into protons
and electrons.
Once again the membrane only allows protons
to pass through it, while electrons flow through
an external circuit to the cathode.This flow
of electrons is the electricity that is used
to power the vehicles electric motors.
If the fuel cell is powered with pure hydrogen,
it has the potential to be up to around 60%
efficient, with most of the wasted energy
lost to heat.
Like hydrogen fuel cells, batteries also come
with inefficiencies and energy losses.
The grid provides AC current while the batteries
store the charge in DC.
So to convert AC to DC, we need a charger.
Using the Tesla Model S as an example, its
peak charger efficiency is around 92%.
The Tesla model S runs on AC motors; therefore,
to convert the DC current supplied by the
batteries into AC current, an inverter has
to be used with an efficiency of roughly 90%.
Additionally, lithium ion batteries can lose
energy due to leakage.
A good estimate for the charging efficiency
of a lithium ion battery is 90%.
All of these factors combined lead to a total
efficiency of around 75%.
However, hydrogen fuel cell vehicles also
have some of these same inefficiencies.
Any kind of electrolysis requires DC current,
and therefore, a rectifier will be required
to convert the AC current from the grid to
DC.
The conversion efficiency here is 92%.
We also need to convert the DC current produced
by the fuel cell to AC to power the motor
through an inverter with an efficiency of
90%.
Finally, the efficiency of the motor must
be considered for both fuel cell and battery
powered vehicles.
Currently, this is around 90-95% for both
of them, which is amazing when you consider
that internal combustion engines running on
petrol have an efficiency of only around 20-30%.
If we add up all these inefficiencies and
compare current generation batteries, to the
best and worst case scenario of current gen
hydrogen.
We can see how they measure up.
Even with the BEST case scenario.
Not taking into account any transport due
to onsite production, and assuming very high
electrolysis efficiency of 80%, and assuming
a HIGH fuel cell efficiency of 80%, hydrogen
still comes out at less than half the efficiency.
The worst case scenario is even worse off.
So while you may be able to go further on
one fill-up of hydrogen in your fuel cell
vehicle over a battery powered electric vehicle,
the cost that is needed to deliver that one
fill up would be astronomically higher compared
to charging batteries due to these energy
losses and efficiencies.
Based on our worst case scenario, we would
expect the cost per kilometre to be about
3.5 times greater for hydrogen, but as we
saw earlier it’s actual 8 times the price.
So additional costs of production unrelated
to efficiencies are obviously at play.
The cost of construction of the facility is
one and the profit the station will take from
sale is another.
For now, these inefficiencies and costs are
driving the market, where most investment
and research is going into battery powered
electric vehicles.
So which wins?
Both are equally more green than internal
combustion engines, assuming equal renewable
resources are used to power them.
Fuel cells allow for fast fill up times and
long ranges; a big advantage.
But battery powered vehicles might catch up
in range by the time there are enough hydrogen
stations to ever make fuel cell vehicles viable.
While fuel cells are efficient relative to
combustion engines, they are not as efficient
as batteries.
They may make more sense for operation disconnected
from the grid or as we saw in our last video
using hydrogen for planes actually could make
a lot of sense, but once again that’s a
topic for another video.
For now, battery powered electric vehicles
seem to be the sensible choice going forward
in the quest for pollution free consumer transport.
As battery-powered cars become more common,
we’re also starting to see self-driving
cars become the norm.
If the job of driver is slowly automated away
and consumers have a bunch of free time to
read or watch online video, it may be wise
to use that opportunity to start learning
new skills and Skillshare is great place to
do it.
You could take this course on Photoshop for
beginners and learn a skill that has helped
this channel immensely.
You may have noticed that we introduced a
new thumbnail design the channel.
This done in part because the channels views
we trending downwards for past 2 months, despite
putting extra effort into production quality.
We needed to rethink our strategy for branding,
and I felt the blueprints strength was that
it was easily recognisable as mine, but they
all also look so similar it’s difficult
to tell when there is a new video.
So we got to work in photoshop to use the
strengths of blueprint design and build on
its weaknesses and we can up with this transitioning
effect.
Taking designs to reality, which I think fits
the theme channel perfectly.
We saw immediate effects with the views on
our last video jumping 80% compared on our
2 month average.
This is the power of illustration and you
can learn how to use software like Photoshop
and Illustrator on Skillshare
These days you can teach yourself pretty much
any skill online and Skillshare is a fantastic
place to do it.
With over 20,000 classes ranging from animation,
electronics, programming and much more.
The classes follow a clear learning curve,
so you just click and watch without having
to curate your own learning experience.
A Premium Membership begins around $10 a month
for unlimited access to all courses, but the
first 1000 people to sign up with this link
will get their first 2 months for free.
So ask yourself right now.
What skill have you been putting off learning.
What project have you been dreaming of completing,
but you aren’t sure if you have the skills
to do it.
Why not start right now and sign up to Skillshare
using the link below to get your first 2 months
free.
You have nothing to lose and a valuable life
skill to gain.
As usual thanks for watching and thank you
to all my Patreon supporters.
If you would like to see more from me, the
links to my twitter, facebook, discord server,
subreddit and instagram pages are below.
I’m about to do a Q&A on the subject matter
of this video on my instagram stories, so
if you are interested in having some questions
answered the link for that is belo